I think the best thing about this is
most people don't know about and they
come for the first time I mean didn't
realize that this type of thing could
happen team Brent know what it is but
it's the kids when you see what their
change and then they go on in years to
come will see him again yeah and we'll
go look they were recognized by people
you just never know what the talent is
was like you surprised every year
Natalie mail more coming home gold but
then when you gave her that ward she did
look like wow yeah this is something got
ya she won't be more the fact i was
dressed up like some kind of weird spot
any she notice bellick loser it
certainly beats that knows me on a
normal night yeah yeah it was the mac
that was worried yeah underneath there
over the trophy yeah are we hope it was
something yeah I'm Mandy whittlin and i
work at woman is sportscenter d prime
life and I've won the category herbs
service to health and fitness award and
I'm very happy to win thank you this is
the car I teach class at Broadmeadow
SportsCenter and it's a prime life class
which is for over 50s of any ability and
we do a monday on a friday classic step
class and robux Sandra Parrish room from
the mid devon advertiser
the mid devon advertiser is extremely
proud to be associated with this very
prestigious event and we're being
delighted to be asked to be a sponsor we
love giving the publicity to the event
and we also love giving the award to the
sports correspondent of the year because
without their support our sports section
would not be what it is and I think it's
just wonderful how much time people give
not only to helping with the sport but
then also to putting in regular and a
high quality reports to the appetizer
thank you very much